Speaker 1: Failed. Former President Donald Trump
gave an interview to Joanne's channel. Ryan which
should be a very, very friendly and positive
interview. She brought up NF, a.k.a. Trump's
recent grift of selling NFT digital trading cards.
Sorry I can't even do it with Steve Bannon said
is not good, that Trump should not be doing
it, that whoever came up with the idea should
be fired. She brings it up to him, and Trump
basically says he thought the nfts were cute.
This should have gone well and it did not
go very well. Let's take a listen to this.
Speaker 5: I'm asking you as as Donald Trump,
the money man. I mean, you have invested your
life intangible assets. And so the question is,
are you looking at Nfts as this kind of
this new world of cryptocurrency that is.
Speaker 1: Sir, is the new world for the physical
asset guy Trump, who did real estate now digital
trading cards. Is this the future of money.
Speaker 5: Future or is it just your playing?
Speaker 2: I viewed it differently. I
didn't view it as investment. I viewed
it as I thought they were cute. I mean, good.
Speaker 1: The former president thought the NFT
is this channel. This is not an investment.
Okay. But this is definitely, definitely
not an investment. It's just cute for $99.
Speaker 2: You're getting these these visions
that are very beautiful and interesting, I think.
Speaker 1: Yes. Me wearing a space suit for
99 bucks. It's so it's just cute.
Speaker 2: And I viewed it that way
much more so than as an NFT. Yeah, but NFT, as
you know, is very hot. Two or three years ago.
Speaker 1: NFT is hot.
Speaker 2: It cooled down. You know,
it's a category that happens at cool down.
So when they announce its NFT, everyone said,
what's he doing that for? That's so cold.
Speaker 1: It was it was
the reaction of many. That's true.
Speaker 2: And they did it. And I guess it was one
of the most successful. Maybe the most successful,
but it was certainly in terms of speed,
the whole thing was sold out almost immediately.
Speaker 1: Imagine if we had said in 2016,
in the next six years, Donald Trump
will win a Republican primary.
Defeat Hillary Clinton in a general election. Do
all the insane stuff he did for the four years.
Then lose to Joe Biden in 2020. Claim that he won.
Wage a two year war during which he drifts tens of
millions from his followers to supposedly overturn
the results. Support a bunch of candidates who
lose in 2022 and then sell NFT digital trading
cards and appear on oann to say that they're cute.
Nobody would have believed that. Absolutely
nobody would have. In fact, I can't think
of a single person who would have taken that bet.
And it is really, really something else to see. I
agree in a sense with Steve Bannon that the entire
trading card thing is completely humiliating. But
the truth is, Trump does humiliating things all
the time. And so I don't know that it's uniquely
humiliating. It'll be interesting to see if and
what the next thing is. And the the hypothesis
that is increasingly forming is Trump may be
realizing that this 2024 run is not going to go
well. And if and when Trump starts to believe
that he may end up having to bail before the
first primaries, as some have have suggested
may happen, he is going to go into grift mode,
which is what is the most amount of money I can
pull out of this before I quietly go away and say,
that's the end of my political career.
And then this starts to make sense,
which is what is just on this side of the law
that I can use to pick up a few extra million
before I just kind of quietly go away. And if
you look at it in that sort of framework with
that idea, then the NFT thing makes a lot
of sense. So even Trump not really making
sense in trying to explain why he did the
NFT thing. There's nothing cute about them,
but that's the explanation that
he's giving at this point in time.